hi I'm Anthony Jeselnik famous handsome
comedian but this is a podcast so being
handsome really doesn't help you out
that much this is Greg Rosenthal analyst
for the NFL Network for now I do want to
keep my job with the NFL impossible
you're gonna get divorced you're gonna
lose your job and I'll probably end up
with your children that wouldn't be that
bad of an outcome for them we talk about
sports off-the-field issues comedy
people are gonna be excited everywhere I
go people just go up our jvb
yeah our jvp is dead now it's good Jay
our VP the Jessen looking rosenthal
vanity project you can download it
subscribe you do whatever you want we
can't really believe that this is
happening again three years after the
NFL took us off their airway I just
can't believe you keep talking about the
old podcast I think you got to give a
little shout out to the old listeners
just to say that it existed before
people move on with their lives
subscribe please it'll be better than
last time hmm half of its gonna be great
you